There's the guy right there.
Hey, you Clint?
- Yeah.
Hey, I'm Mike.
Hi.
Nice to meet you.
Talked to Danielle on the phone.
Or your kids talk
to her on the phone.
- Yeah.
- Frank.
What's going on?
I know that my son and
daughter contacted Danielle,
because they've been
talking to me about, dad,
you need to downsize.
But it's hard to do.
Was this the Ford garage?
Danielle said you had a--
Yeah, it's the Ford garage.
Built in 1919.
- No kidding.
- Yeah.
This building originally
was a Ford dealership.
It was called Meils Garage.
And I'd be the third
or fourth owner.
So when you
bought it, was there
any remnants of that in there?
- No.
The guy said he never
kept into the advertising
because he just threw it away.
It was worthless back then.
Yeah
Yeah.
So I told myself I'd never
fill this up, but I did.
And people have tried to sell
me other buildings here in town,
and I said, no, because
I'd just fill them up.
So I've tried to control
the habit a little bit.
- Wow, this is cool.
- Nice building.
- Can we look inside?
- Sure.
All right.
Wow.
It's amazing how you can
roll into these small towns
where there looks
like there's nothing,
and then walk into a
building with so much stuff.
How many square feet
is this building?
7,500.
No kidding.
Quite a bit.
I've noticed over here
you got your workbench.
- Yeah.
- So this is the hang, right?
Yeah.
I come down here every day.
And people say, what do
you do down here all day?
And I said, I don't know.
But I don't get it done, so I
got to come back the next day.
He's got 7,500
square feet, and he's
got it packed to the max.
I know my kids want me to
downsize, and I know I need to.
But I still get a rush
when I buy something,
and when I sell something
occasionally, you know?
Sometimes people get
kind of ornery with me
that I won't sell them
something, but it's like, OK,
you know.
It's my stuff.
I get this say whether
I sell it or not.
Is that sign right there,
is that metal or is it wood?
- No, it's wood.
- Looks like a fiber board.
- Yeah.
- Was that a local piece?
I see it's Illinois.
- Yeah.
I bought it at an auction.
What do you value
the magic of that?
I really don't
want to sell it.
You don't want
to sell that piece?
No.
So do you have a 'I don't
want to sell it' price?
Or no?
$3,000.
- That's a big number for it.
- Yeah.
It's his 'I don't want to sell
it' number, but he's putting
a number on it.
And when you put a
number on something,
that opens up a conversation.
What about this Chicago
Motor Club Service station?
If you want my 'I don't want
to sell it' price, $7,000.
Wow.
So you're into the
gas and oil stuff.
I can see some advertising.
A little bit so.
What do you value
the case sign at?
- Not for sale price is $3500.
OK.
It feels like we just taught
this guy a new negotiating
trick, and he really likes it.
I hope we didn't just
shoot ourself in the foot.
- Clint.
- Yes.
I found a table.
This is the biggie.
Where'd that come out of?
Came out of a drugstore.
No kidding.
He's got this incredible
13 foot table.
The bottom of it is all
grain painted, turn legs.
It's beautiful.
So what do you value this at?
My 'I don't want to
sell it' price is $2,500.
Now is the table worth that?
Absolutely.
Yeah, you're right on the money.
It's a good piece.
But I can't pay that, and
he knows that. $2,500.
Yeah, I can't.
At some point, his I don't
want to sell it price might
be my 'I want to buy it' price.
Clint, what have we
got going on those here?
It's a three piece sign, here.
It's porcelain.
Clover Farms Store And Meats.
Thing about these
signs is, you've got
to have the right space for it.
It's 15 foot plus sign there.
Is it something you would sell?
If you want my 'I don't want
to sell it' price, $4,000.
$4,000.
You really don't
want to sell it.
Yeah.
He's learned a
new catch phrase,
but now he's taking
it to the extreme.
My 'I don't want
to sell it' price.
'I don't want to sell' price.
'I don't to sell' price, $2,500.
I'm glad you didn't buy it,
because I want to put it
on the front of the building.
Because my very first store
was a Clover Farm store.
Oh, you used to shop
when you're a kid or?
No, it was--
I rented it for $25 a month to
start my first antique shop.
That seems awful cheap.
Where was that at?
Little corner grocery
store in Williamsburg, Iowa.
1967.
- Williamsburg, Iowa?
- Yeah.
I just stopped and got
gas there a minute ago.
So how did you end up there?
- I taught there.
- At the high school?
- Right.
OK.
How old were you when
you opened up the shop?
I was 23.
And I was 21 when I
first started teaching.
So you were teaching
and running a shop.
Yeah.
So, just on nights and weekends,
and that kind of thing.
Yeah.
I tried to make
enough money to be
able to buy something to keep.
So it was kind of like that's
how I funded the obsession,
I guess.
- Retail's a monster, man.
Oh, yeah.
And whatever people wanted,
I didn't want to sell.
And I always tell
them my 'I don't want
to sell it' price so--
it's not a good
business model, is it?
Now that Clint told me
the story about the sign,
I don't blame him.
I wouldn't sell it either.